he's an American businessman and
politician he has a net worth of 250
million dollars he co-founded and let
the spin-off company Bain Capital he is
Mitt Romney and here are his top ten
rules for today I believe having a clear
vision of where you want to go and and
being able to articulate that to
yourself perhaps writing it down I tend
to I take out that the notes section of
my iPad and and will will write down
what it is I want to accomplish and
think about precisely what I hope to
accomplish with a particular assignment
so I'll write that down so having a
clear objective I think is important to
hear the expression all the time you
know the grass is greener on the other
side of the fence but don't forget you
could only make the grass greener on
your own side of the fence you can't
change the color of the grass over there
you could only change the color of the
fence on your side and so the real issue
is where is the best opportunity where
can you find opportunities in your life
where's an opportunity for instance to
start a new business I met a lot of
entrepreneurs who started businesses and
most folks think that they're going to
sit down in their study and think and
think and read magazines and trying to
find some opportunity that that'll allow
them to become rich by starting a
business I haven't found a lot of people
do that most of the people that I have
found that we're successful in starting
a business of their own looked around
them in the job they already had and and
looked for opportunities that weren't
being filled by their their current
enterprise looked for customer needs
that weren't being met look for
something that this wasn't working
particularly well through all the
occupations I'm at I've experienced
successes and as you know failures I'm
asked what it felt like to lose to
President Obama not as good as winning
failures aren't fun but they are
inevitable more importantly failures
don't define who you are
some people measure their life by their
secular successes how high in the
corporate lighter they got how much
money they made did they do better than
their high school classmates if that's
the kind of success you're looking for
you're bound to be disappointed life has
way too much chance in serendipity to be
assured fame or fortune you need to have
a life coach you need to have someone
who'll tell you the truth tell you that
the perfect mate you've been looking for
is no more perfect than you are tell you
when you're wrong tell you what you need
to do to make things right I can assure
you that finding someone who cares
enough about you to tell you the truth
and then is willing to take time to give
you their counsel and their coaching
that's invaluable look for it my path in
life has primarily been focused on doing
things I thought were fun and enjoyable
and so that was fun I mean my my
undergraduate major was English and I
said why would you go into English what
I mean there's no future right as I
think English major what are you gonna
do alright and and but I like reading
and I liked writing so when I took
English is my major and then coming out
of business school in law school I
wanted a consulting because I enjoyed it
not because that's where I thought I'd
spend my life I expected that I'd be
there for two or three years like most
people do and then get a job in a in a
line corporation of some kind and and
and perhaps move up more aggressively by
having started in consulting I loved
consulting because I am I oriented
towards solving problems I like analysis
and data and problem solving and writing
and writing presentations that's what I
like to do that's what took me there and
so I would I would go to those I
followed the career path that you enjoy
most as opposed to trying to follow a
career path that you think will will
lead to the highest income or the the
quickest promotion do what you enjoy and
and then your life will be enjoyable and
fulfilling I'm gonna draw a familiar
account from the life of the Savior to
help me describe what I believe is a
secret to abundant living you recall
that Peter and the other fisherman
been unsuccessful in catching fish and
the master directed them to return to
their boats to go out deeper and to let
down their nets again which they did and
when they did so they were met with
enormous success these were the words
the lucra cords that the master spoke he
said this launch out into the deep and
let down your nets launch out into the
deep and let down your nets in some ways
these wards are a metaphor for life
launch out into the deep don't live in
the shallows live it in the deep waters
grasp every ennobling experience is
available to you embrace every dimension
of living that challenges you that
educates you that that elevates you live
for purposes greater than yourself lose
yourself in the service of others reach
beyond the shallowness of selfishness
and complacency and mindless conformity
and of indulgence this is the promise
launch out into the deep and your nets
will be filled
I did something to keep things in
perspective to keep myself grounded at
the top of a sheet of paper that was
always placed on the podium so we could
make notes during the debate just before
the debate kicked off I wrote at the top
one word dad I also drew a small image
of the Sun and throughout the debate
when I glanced down at that paper to
look at my notes that I'd taken I was
reminded of my father's fearlessness in
fighting for what he believed was right
and the Sun that reminded me of course
of that familiar scripture lets your
light so shine we don't lose that debate
I hoped I would never do anything that
would dishonor or discredit the things I
hold most dear now during your life
you're going to encounter circumstances
that make you sweat for many of you the
exams and tests won't be over when you
graduate and you're all going to stand
at podiums stand in front of a boss to
ask for a raise
or work on some critical project in your
employment that'll make a big difference
in your life at moments like those
perspective is a very powerful friend
you can welcome perspective through
preparatory prayer by considering the
blessings of the temple or by simply
glancing at your CTR ring find ways to
keep your life in perspective and if
you're spending all your time in one
aspect of your life and not devoting it
to other things that are important to
you then obviously things are out of
whack a couple of things I backed into
you're in the joint program business law
program I I came from Brigham Young
University to Harvard and was convinced
I would flunk out and because I looked
around I saw these people who were
obviously smarter than me and and how
was I possibly gonna make it in this
environment except by just studying like
crazy and so I studied all the time and
if I was not studying I felt like
there's this black cloud hanging over me
I should be studying I've got to be
working because I'm gonna flunk out and
and it was it was omnipresent and at
some point I finally said you know what
I'm gonna do something which which goes
back to biblical times I'm gonna take
sunday off I'm gonna decide I'm not
gonna study at all on Sunday and I'm
gonna devote that day to my family to
worship and just personal time and it
was amazing what happened when I made
that decision because then on that
Sunday I didn't feel the black cloud
there anymore it's like okay I I can't
study today I don't have to worry about
it and and the same thing happened as I
went into my career in the consulting
industry I said you know what I'm just
not gonna work when I come home at the
end of the day it may be a late night
and maybe I get home at six or seven
instead but when I come home I'm gonna
close my brief briefcase and that work
and I'm gonna devote the time I have at
home to my family and it was wonderful
it was just it was it was freeing
because I could really focus on the
things that I cared most about in life
which which were my wife and my kids
your job will expand your skills
will demand your ability your energy and
your time hardwork ennobling work dive
into your profession with passion and
hearts go beyond what's expected or
required and in doing so by the way you
will learn the secret to advancement and
that is doing your present job well each
of you here will influence other lives
think of that perhaps you'll shape
history perhaps you'll shape one
person's history consider with care how
you act what you say and do what you're
gonna do you're life - because I assure
you your choices will shape the lives of
other people thank you guys so much for
watching I made this video because I am
Bergesen asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur you want me to profile next
leave it in the comments below and I'll
see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of the ten
rules meant the most to you had the
biggest impact leave it in the comments
I'm gonna join in the discussion thank
you guys so much for watching
it key to believe and I'll see you soon